the corona virus pandemic is forcing
most high school seniors to say goodbye
to their teachers or classmates in a
virtual graduation ceremony so we asked
some of this year's student speakers to
share their speeches with us with us is
what she's trying to say they came from
across the country and all are at the
top of their class thank you very much
here are their messages to the class of
2020
I'm mechanical and I'm Kaila go as we
are Co many things we are to of Mirko
Dadich torian's for the Northwood high
school class of 2020 elect our knowledge
that we've made it this marks the end of
the chapter but also the beginning of a
new one
dear TAS last time class of 2020 our
high school journey is nearing an end
like Jennifer Gale said some days you
will be the light for others and some
days you will need some light from them
we are resilient we were born on the
brink of 9/11 a terrorist attack on the
country they killed thousands and
changed the lives of so many others and
now our senior year is cut short by a
pandemic it has taken the world hold it
hostage when I was eight we couldn't
leave our house because the Ivory Coast
wireless was in the middle of a civil
war people were dying I heard gunshots
right outside of the house never did I
think I will be living a similar reality
music has allowed me to distance myself
from the stresses of home in school our
school-wide town show was for the first
time fully student-led and produced we
expected to create lifelong celebration
memories instead those memories began to
fill with cancellations
we stand amid one of the largest global
disruptions in history how can we not
envy what other students had in years
prior the full senior year experience
with all that we have lost it can be
easy to forget we gained the community
of teachers who loved us and taught us
that our ideas have value we learned how
to be good teammates students citizens
and friends at home we took care of our
family members learned how to cook bake
and even figured out how to do things
around the house these are the times or
we must remember that these are the
exact conditions that a seed must endure
before it is able to blossom into a
beautiful plant
we are those plants this year may become
an unwelcome reminder of the fragility
of guaranties it has the potential to
teach us strength and flexibility for
future endeavors as we seek to
accomplish our individual goals and
collectively make improvements to
society the class of 2020 is overcoming
all these troubles and that shows me
that were ready for ever comes next
[Music]
we don't have to look far to see how our
class is already succeeding in the real
world recently over two dozen teachers
and students came together to 3d print
over 4,000 masks and face shields
this pandemic has given us a glimpse
into the infinite possibilities of
change we are destined to make we have
built an endurance that is likely to
lead us through the rest of our lives
I can only imagine what we'll do when
this is over
class of 2020 despite the current
challenges and obstacles be prepared for
what's coming your way so many
opportunities this is just the beginning
and remember as long as there is life
there is hope we are excited to see how
you our contribution shape our world
that's so great congratulations class of
2020 giving you a high-five through the
camera also bravo Bravo to Joe long the
great producer we worked with him
Anthony many times meg mystery associate
producer and Craig Shay the editor we
work with that team they are knockout
because you and I know these stories are
so hard to do with no track and I also
like the fact that the team gave them
the opportunity to say what they wanted
to say a different platform they should
be celebrated you're right they will
have a great story to tell their kids
down the road they sure will and as Tony
pointed out it's not just a finish line
it's a starting line for the next the
next chapter but they're gonna be ready
but after going through this they'll be
ready for anything